[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et world sa et timide jacques bois
très
vigoureuse comme feu et demi comme vous
plaindre d'être à cannes elle nous
confie plein de services comme la nef
l'ex just want want to its all good
things you man
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un ami belge nous sommes ici à
bruxelles chez walid à je prépare la
tout dernièrement dans laquelle je
glisse comme promis un golden ticket que
je vais signer de la main et la personne
qui tombera sur cette commande avec le
code d'éthique est gagnera un voyage à
marrakech pour des personnes attention
c'est valable uniquement
numérique ses fonctions
ouais maman
je suis chez walid à à bruxelles regarde
ça y est ça y est
c'est cool hein c'est qui
c'est comme un petit coucou
format bravo et a monté une
multinationale étaient présentes en
belgique
[Musique]
alors j'ai fait une petite sieste dans
la voiture et je me suis arrivé j'avais
mal au cou et je me disais pourquoi elle
met au cou
avait peut-être tout simplement parce
que je dors comme ça
la longueur
non mais c'est quoi ça
[Musique]
comment je peux la bourse de plus non
mistoufle et parfois non non non non qu
est ce que je peux avoir soupé s'il te
plaît tu te plait merci en plus c'est le
dernier je crois